ich rege mich fürchterlich auf über die
volksverdummung die die spd versucht mit
uns zu veranstalten in ihrem neuesten
wahlwerbespot verkaufen sie uns olaf
scholz als erben von hans schmidt nun
ist die heutige spd so weit von helmut
schmidt entfernt das dass das so eine
aussage einfach an verlogenheit nicht zu
überbieten ist ein helmut schmidt wurde
heute zum beispiel mit seinen meinungen
zur immigrations thema von der spd als
zutiefst reaktionär abgelehnt werden ein
helmut schmidt würde es in einer
heutigen spd nicht wenn man mehr zum
bezirksvorsitzenden schafften
du hast ein punkt vielleicht nicht so
radikal aber im helmut schmidt ist
natürlich in teilen auch an der spd
gescheitert
er hat damals den in den 80er jahren die
nato doppelbeschluss durchgesetzt hat
gesagt die russen die sowjets damals
haben mehr mittelstreckenraketen wir
haben gar keine und er hat dafür
plädiert dass dieses fenster der
verwundbarkeit wie er es genannt hat
geschossen wird und die spd ist ihm zwar
zähneknirschend gefolgt aber für die war
das eine perverse logik waffen mit noch
mehr waffen eben negieren zu wollen
egalisieren zu wollen und dann war dann
1982 schluss die jährlich aus diesen
gründen weil die partei ihn nicht mehr
gefolgt ist ähnlich gerhard schröders
agenda 2010 tolle arbeitsmarktreform die
das handelsblatt heute noch feiert am
heutigen tag aber
natürlich die rennen teil seiner ernte
hat angela merkel eingefahren 16 jahre
lang aufschwung oder relativ gute
wirtschaftsdaten also insofern sind
beide an der spd gescheitert und man
kann helmut schmidt auch nicht in diesem
wahlspot vereinnahmen aber das hat sich
erwiesen hat ja so unterschwellig da
wird der eid von helmut schmidt denen er
spricht da unterschiedlich eingewoben
häußlein also auf der tonspur und es
wird gesagt naja als helmut schmidt
kanzler wagen aber 1975 da des olaf
scholz mit 17 jahren in die spd
eingetreten soweit also unterschwellig
lieber würde ich jetzt nicht sagen
sondern das ist schon genau gemacht man
hätte ja auch willy brandt nehmen können
man hat auch gerhard schröder nehmen
aber dann kannst du uns vorhaben noch
nicht
ja aber aber man hätte ein von den
beinen und beide haben die tatsächliche
oft zusammengesessen irgendwann hatte
olaf scholz auch die weihe der sagte der
altkanzler
komm mal vorbei bei mir in langenhain da
gab es mal so freitags runde und da
durfte urlaub auch sitzen und zuhören
aber das ist doch immer vorbei geht dass
das ja ich war einmal ein blenden würden
glaubst es würde die wirkung noch mal
verstärken zu zeigen wie das schlagzeug
gerne können haben sie ihr habt ja live
dementsprechend können wir immer mal
schauen ob wir den werbespot jetzt kurz
mal an machen könnten die regie das war
ganz ganz toll ich schwöre dass ich
meine kraft dem wohle des deutschen
volkes widmen
meine pflichten gewissenhaft erfüllen
und gerechtigkeit gegen jedermann üben
werde so wahr mir gott helfe als schmidt
deutschland aus der krise führte stieg
er für dich in die politik ein als
arbeitsrechtler kämpfte er an deiner
seite für gerechtigkeit in ost und west
als arbeits und sozialminister sicherte
sein kurzarbeitergeld die jobs viele
mütter und väter und als erster
bürgermeister von hamburg sorgte er für
wohnungsbau wie kein zweiter als es um
verantwortung für unser land gehen
aber trotzdem der intesa hat sie jetzt
noch mal gezeigt und die bäder du hast
nicht du hast meine kritiker daran nicht
verstanden ich selbstverständlich
scheitert jeder große bundeskanzler
irgendwann an seine eigene partei das
ist fast ein historisches continuo über
merkels irgendwann ja nur darum aber gut
aber
das ist doch das ist doch irgendwie
interessant dass gerade bei der spd
große bundeskanzler oft sich gegen
sozusagen das leider die eigene partei
werden muss das ist aber nicht mein
punkt mein punkt ist das ist die
verlogenheit der spd sich heute
darzustellen ist eine partei die
irgendwie noch in der kontinuität von
helmut schmidt steht der für eine
gewisses bürgerliches reservoir der spd
steht die längst verloren gegangen ist
warum zeigen sie in diesem werbespot
keine frau eske ennen warum zeigen sie
den herrn kein kühn hat warum zeigen sie
jemanden der seit 40 jahren nicht meiner
politik ist weil sie natürlich gerne
heutigen personale leute verängstigen
würden ich habe mir interviews mit herrn
kühne angehört dort wird der enteignung
gesprochen und zwar nicht nur in einem
von groh von von irgendwelchen
milliardären sondern er will der will
ganze firmen enteignung wie das
funktioniert dann hat man ja im ost er
ist vielleicht noch nicht alt genug um
mitzubekommen dass all das schon mal
probiert worden ist in osteuropa das ist
ziemlich schief gegangen auch in
venezuela läuft es nicht so toll also
diese idee dass ein dass das die mit sp
ich sag jetzt mal ganz deutlich auch
wenn sie beweisen hier dabei sind was
helmut schmidt zum thema immigration
sagt es ist heute so politisch inkorrekt
wenn sie sich alte interviews mit
meischberger zum beispiel anschauen er
würde heute rechts von sarrazin stehen
der würde hätte ein
parteiausschlussverfahren am hals das
heißt mit ihm in den wahlkampf zu ziehen
ist einfach schlicht verlogen aber die
spd zieht ja auch gar nicht unbedingt
auf die aktuellen spd wähler
das foto von olaf scholz denken da geht
es um ganz andere wähler da geht es
nämlich genau um wähler die
möglicherweise sonst armin laschet
gewählt hätten die vielleicht auch von
der afg zurückgeholt werden sollen wie
auch immer die vielleicht auch bei den
grünen schon waren und dachten sie
könnten annalena baerbock wählen die
vielleicht auch christian lindner eine
zeit lang ganz gut fanden und jetzt
zurückgeholt werden also diese raute
zeigt ja auch mehr es ist eigentlich
nicht olaf scholz ist auch helmut merkel
so ein bisschen der da jetzt antritt
also das soll jetzt die aufbruchstimmung
sein also ist wenn ich mich wenn ich
einen wunsch habe ich wünsche mir
aufbruchstimmung wissen doch jetzt alle
einig geworden durch die letzten krisen
das wiedersehen das eben gerade genannt
dass wir der nachholbedarf an
infrastruktur ich möchte jetzt nicht die
ganze reihe herunterbeten ihr kennt sie
alle aber wollte mir ehrlich sagen dass
wir dass wir mit olaf scholz ein
aufbruchstimmung erzeugen können
geworden oder hier alles erleben wollen
wir wollen ich glaube ich im ja wir
haben vielleicht richtige wahl zwischen
pest und cholera aber in dem fall ist
mit cholera lieber weil ich eine flasche
zu trauern team zusammenzustellen und
bei der köpfe sind in dieses land
regieren und ich eine spd die vorgibt
konservative bürgerliche partei zu sein
aber mit dem mit der pds oder die sich
inzwischen heißt geschäfte macht und vor
allem ein mit einem mann antritt der für
alle steht aber für eines nicht aber
weil der aufbruchstimmung ist ja ich
meine das ist ja nichts neues und das
versucht man ja immer oder abscheu zu
entlocken wie halten sie es mit der pds
oder mit der sogenannten linkspartei und
er sagt dann immer nur na ja ich möchte
gerne mit einer partei koalieren die in
der nato auch bleiben will und sagt
natürlich nicht mit der nicht aber wenn
wir uns einmal angucken es gibt ja
neueste umfragen was die
lieblingskoalition der deutschen ist mit
37 prozent vorne ist die ampelkoalition
erstaunlicherweise und danach rot rot
grün nicht grün rot rot das ist ganz
hinten aber rot-rot-grün
das heißt irgendetwas ist passiert seit
dieser rote socken kampagne 1994 was die
leute gesagt hat ich bin auch kein fan
davon dass wir uns nicht missverstehen
aber es ist einfach anders und auf
nummer eins wie gesagt die
ampelkoalition was auch iris war gerade
aber konkret wenn die meisten wähler
fehler oder eine relative mehrheit
mittlerweile spd wählt das die im
zweifel auch sagen wir wollen eine
ampelkoalition von der fdp
beispielsweise ist bekannt dass nur ein
ganz ganz geringer teil gerne eine ampel
koalition gehen würde die würden lieber
ein bündnis mit den schwarzen und den
grünen zum beispiel wählen aber es ist
nicht verwunderlich wenn die spd frauen
liegt das auch dann mehrheitlich es hat
bis jemals am fünfziger jahren ist es
nicht okay wieder so eine rolle das hat
aber alles ich glaube ich muss sagen
wahlkampf ist ja immer verlogen so und
das passiert natürlich auf 19 1 das sagt
mir dann meinen verein weiter ist
verloren
nein wir sehen das natürlich an dem spot
wir sehen nicht verraten da auch
reinfallen wahlkampf ist und wenn ich an
dem punkt einig und und der woher kurz
gericht genau das von mir auch in den
meetings gesagt hat mich auch darum gibt
haben mal auch darum gebeten ihm nicht
ständig kontra zu geben und ihn nicht
ständig eine links und rechts zu geben
aber ich habe gesagt dafür bin ich nicht
da aber bohlen ich weiß gar nicht wieso
hier überhaupt über scholz und über
scholz werbespot weil
wahlwerbespot reden ganz ehrlich das
macht das superweib das schlimme sich
durch der wartet der wartet ab bis die
werburg den nächsten block abschießt bis
der laschet über den nächsten lacher
lacht und eine schlängelt sich durch
also ich weiß gar nicht der typ macht
das super ich glaube das ist der moment
liegen ich glaube es ist mehr ich glaube
es ist die sehnsucht ja mir gerade einen
krisenzeit und menschen sehen sich
glaube ich in krisenzeiten nach
verlässlichkeit und die zeigt natürlich
stolz sei natürlich ein absoluter
vorteil man kennt ihn das sagt jetzt
nicht aber man kennt ihn ein und alles
nur meine brüste standen auch schon vor
ihm bei einer aktion in hamburg
starten vorschlag tatsächlich haben wir
schon eine aktion
in seiner rede am 18 dabei heben da sie
waren ja auch mitbegründerin von filmen
genau deutschnationale zelle gegründet
ja keine ahnung verängstigt
übrigen drei hat hat reagiert
so schön aber so im ganzen war es okay
machen wir das heute auch noch nein nein
heute.de erstens im fünften monat ist
das ein bisschen schwierig zweitens habe
ich mich doch weiterentwickelt haben
nackte brüste waren dann doch nur eine
politische ausdrucksform einer meiner
politischen arbeit und ich konzentriere
mich jetzt doch auf angezogen bücher
schreiben reden halten und den kanzler
auf die nerven gehen ja das ist doch
eine schöne entwicklung aber man sagt
doch warum er in der jugend nicht andere
sachen gemacht hat später hat die jugend
nicht gelebt aber ich war vorher schon
cdu-mitglied vor der film brüno aber wie
passt das zusammen als ich meine
konservative werte zu haben und dann den
filmen verein noch mal für den zuschauer
zur einordnung das ist ja darauf
begründet auf oben ohne proteste für den
der film nicht kennt das ist eine
organisation die damit protestiert wie
passt das beides zusammen ich finde es
eine unglaublich spannende mischung bei
ihnen das passt zusammen also die ahg es
schon so gestellt worden und ich wundere
mich selber über diese frage jetzt mal
immer noch und zwar ich bin total
konservativ ich bin total spießig aber
das hat ja mit nacktheit mit nichts zu
tun oder mit falscher scham nichts zu
tun aber viele millionen ja es ist
einfach nur eine protestform um auf
themen aufmerksam zu machen themen zur
diskussion zu bringen und auch gerade
die themen bei den richtigen personen zu
positionieren und es ist einfach eine
künstlerische ausdrucksform gewesen man
hat ja offenbar funktioniert weil
immer wurde die presse also die medien
haben euch gecovert würden sie
eigentlich cdu wählen oder die union
wählen wenn markus söder als
kanzlerkandidat antreten würde ja das
heißt wenn es einen wechsel geben würde
würde ich zumindest meine stimme
mindestens mehr ja auf jeden fall ich
halte ihr ich halte
söder
für fehler in der hinsicht dass er als
dominanter als als kanzler dominanter
auftreten kann uns auch für andere
nationen vernünftig vertreten kann
[Musik]